thanks very much being on the program uh
Mr Burnham so we just mentioned there
the Devolution deal seen there's a bit
of a Trailblazer what are you going to
do with the new powers
yes it's quite exciting actually Sophie
we've got the ability now to have more
control over post 16 technical education
and we've long called for that because I
believe it's an issue that the country
has neglected a new education in England
that's been dominated by the university
route under all parties to be honest so
we have the chance now to fix it so
instead of just there being one clear
route for young people towards
University which starts with English
Baccalaureate then goes to a levels and
then ucas and ends obviously with a
degree we want to create an equivalent
uh route for young people who want a
technical qualification or a good job in
the greater Manchester economy so we're
going to bring in the the Manchester
Baccalaureate that will lead towards T
levels and other technical
qualifications we then have gmax which
is our equivalent of ucas to try and
help people find opportunities in the
greater National economy and then it
takes people to a good apprenticeship a
degree apprenticeship or an other
another higher qualification so it's
really exciting to be honest it's just
the reform that greater Manchester needs
right now we're a really fast growing
successful vibrant modern economy you
can see that in the skyline of our city
center but there's a risk we won't bring
through the talented young people that
we need and this fixes it
you're obviously pretty excited by some
of these opportunities do you think we
should give the government some credit
for being serious about devolving Powers
outside of Westminster
yes and I do you know I very much take a
place first rather than party first
approach in my role as mayor of Greater
Manchester
um and I I try to call it as it is I'm
conscious that when I was elected in
2017 and then again in 2021 people of
all political Persuasions lent me their
support so it's important that I am a
voice that that represents all of that
opinion and puts our place first and the
government does deserve credit for
delivering a Devolution agreement that
takes greater Manchester to the next
level so it's not just more power over
technical education we're going to going
to be able to do something about housing
standards particularly in the private
rented sector by bringing in a greater
Manchester good landlord at Charter also
people know we've been on with a major
reform of public transport next month I
will put out a London style integrated
Fair structure that will make public
transport cheaper in Greater Manchester
and in time we can bring the trains into
to into that integrated system it was a
bit of a victory for the Mayors I have
to say last week when the transport
secretary agreed to our request to bring
transparent Express under under public
control that gives us a real opportunity
now to reshape the railways in the north
and make them work much better for the
public
there's going to be more scrutiny two of
your role right including from
Committees of local MPS and Sky News
recently did a story about a police and
crime commissioner who triggered two
police investigations into his political
opponents do you think there is a risk
that as we give more power to local
bodies whether that's policing crime
Commissioners whether that's Mayors and
partly of course because of the frankly
the decimation of local press that there
is a risk about scrutiny and holding
people to account properly
yes yes I do and I um I worry about it
because you know Devolution in England
is working it really is working you know
just just look at the positive energy
that's flowing around greater Manchester
right now you know we are beginning to
see the rebalancing of the UK economy
and it's and it's a great thing and
obviously when you have power at this
level that we have you can make change
from the bottom up with people I think
kirstano was touching on these themes
yesterday it's really working and I
would hate to see it derail
by some Corrupt Practices of the kind
that you're that you're that you're
mentioning so when I was in the
discussions with the government and they
were saying that they wanted uh Stronger
accountability uh structures and
arrangements and actually conservative
MPS in Greater Manchester were saying
the same thing that they were unhappy
with power being given without you know
the checks and balances and I agreed
with them to us and I said to the
government look you go as far as you
like that's the deal if we get more
power I don't mind at all you know being
called before any parliamentary
committee and in fact what I've
suggested is that the government sets up
a greater Manchester Grand Committee in
Parliament similar to the Scottish brand
committee and the Welsh Grant committee
so there can be full scrutiny of what
we're of what we're doing so you were
right to raise that issue but we don't
we don't fear it at all
now I just want to talk to you a bit
about National politics if I may because
obviously labor did rather well at the
local elections it seems pretty clear
that right now if the polls and if the
local elections were projected onto the
House of Commons it would be Kirsten
number 10. but not necessarily with a
majority
it's your take on this whole round about
the whether care estamos should rule in
or out a coalition with the lib Dems
what do you think
well I don't think he needs to at this
point in time he needs to set out his
his own store uh and he's doing that and
he did that yesterday I read the speech
I don't think the headlines
um did Justice to it it was quite a
considered uh Speech and I think
increasingly now he's got that
opportunity to lay out a program that
will deliver a a good working majority
for him under labor labor government the
local elections told us very clearly
that the public is ready for change uh
and I think he also said it's not yet
you know in the position where it's
completely
um clear that it's you know it's it's a
majority labor government but I think we
will get there and that's the next phase
of the project that I think here in the
shadow cabinet are building and I hope
they can draw on some of the things that
we're doing you know I think it would be
a mistake to suggest this will be like
1997 all over again you know we need to
come up with a program that's right for
the times that we're in I was really
proud obviously to be in that government
and all the great things that we did but
looking back you know I would say we did
neglect some issues so we did Focus too
much on the University route as I was
saying before and we should have done
much more on technical education when it
comes to the NHS it shouldn't always
just be about targets and recruiting
more doctors and nurses we should have
fixed social care when we were in when
we were in power and I'd like to see a
radical agenda kind of developed around
around that as well or if you take
housing promoting home ownership is an
important thing but if you do that on
its own you'll still have a housing
prices and actually you need a housing
policy that's about building more uh
modern Council homes social homes and
also as I said before getting serious
about housing standards in the private
rented rented sector and much stronger
regulation there so develop develop an
agenda that's right for now and labor
will get that majority government and so
it's it's exciting times for the party
if they fall short at the majority then
one of the things the lib Dems could be
demanding is purple representation a
change the voting system do you think
that should be a red line for labor or
do you think it's something that perhaps
labor should also embrace no I do I I
I've come around to it I'll be honest I
I wasn't always in this position but
when you step outside of Westminster you
look at things afresh and you know I
I've looked at how our doesn't really
flow properly throughout this this
country the first pass the post system I
think has more power to the
establishment than it does to um to MPS
actually but beyond that to people and I
think PR would put the people much more
in in control every every vote would
matter and so I've you know I've come
around I've got the Zeal of the convert
I I personally believe if you're going
to really make this country work
properly for all people in all places
It's a combination of proportional
representation for the commons Senator
the Nations and regions to replace the
unelected Lords because how can it be
right in this day and age that you know
all places aren't represented equally in
our national Parliament and then thirdly
I would have maximum Devolution of power
to the uh to the to the regional or city
region level like like we've got in
Greater Manchester that that would make
the country work much better make it
much fairer for everybody and I would
like to see uh that agenda not be not be
taken off the table let's say okay
thanks very much pretty clear always
good to uh talk to you thanks thank you
thank you very much